one of the things we've been talking
about for some time is the republican
party has completely given up on policy
they just they don't even talk about
policy anymore sometimes it sort of
sounds like maybe they're approximating
what might be considered policy but it's
essentially just cultural issues but i
have for you today
a supposed policy platform this is from
republican senator rick scott who
published an 11 point
plan
to quote
rescue america it's delusional depraved
and disgusting and dangerous
and we're going to take a look at what
is on this plan and you will very
quickly see that for the most part this
is just cultural nonsense
masquerading as policy we won't spend a
ton of time on each point but i'll give
you a sense of what they are
point one our kids will say the pledge
of allegiance salute the flag learn that
america is a great country and choose
the school that best fits them
that all together
is an attack on funding of public
schools in favor of charter voucher type
programs
continued opposition to letting teachers
determine how best to teach their
students and
this cultural imposition of salute the
flag
say the pledge of allegiance this is
cultural nonsense masquerading as policy
number two the government will never
again ask american citizens to disclose
their wraith as race ethnicity or skin
color on government forms
they want you to think that those
questions can only be racist or can only
be for wokeness but the reality is that
collecting that information in so many
different ways
allows us to see
whether there are groups
being discriminated against not
necessarily
uh
openly
but
in practice and implicitly and it's
really important that we have that data
we're not looking to use it in the way
republicans claim it should be used but
if you don't collect that data you quite
literally have no idea uh uh whether
there are real inequalities along the
lines of uh race ethnicity and skin
color that we might want to address we
can't even have that conversation if you
don't collect the data okay number three
the soft on crime days of chronic
coddling criminal behavior will end
we will refund the police remember the
police hasn't been defunded and as a
national or state policy these decisions
are basically made at the municipality
level there are some municipalities who
have made changes to we will bring in
social workers or we might not replace
all the police cars right now or
whatever the police have not been
defunded in any systemic way and it's
simply another one of these cultural
issues
okay
number four
and these are kind of all over the map
four we will secure our border finish
building the wall and name it after
president donald trump the wall is
obviously not getting built the wall is
also not the solution to our immigration
problem it's a distraction and naming it
after trump another one of these virtue
signaling nonsense claims
we will grow america's economy starve
washington's economy and stop socialism
so this is an argument number one
against non-existent socialism another
cultural battle that they are fighting
and
code for we will cut social welfare
programs number six we will eliminate
all federal programs that can be done
locally
and enact term limits for federal
bureaucrats in congress term limits i'm
actually open to
but again eliminating all federal
programs that can be done locally a lot
of programs can be done locally but it
doesn't make any sense to and that's
another way to simply cut welfare number
seven we will protect the integrity of
american democracy and stop left-wing
efforts to rig elections straight up
projection
trump tried stealing the election
and they are now just projecting that on
to the left
total
nonsense cultural war issue number eight
we will protect defend and promote the
american family at all costs saying the
nuclear family is crucial to
civilization that can have within it
any number of homophobic
transphobic
and other disgusting aspects
number nine men are men women are women
and unborn babies are babies so both
transphobic and anti-abortion
number 10 americans will be free to
welcome god into all aspects of our
lives
very clearly trying to take down
separation of church and state
bring prayer back to school etc etc and
number 11 we are americans not
globalists which is sort of an allusion
to this america first nationalism type
rhetoric
not a surprise that that's also
something they want to push this is a
plan guys it's an 11-point plan
nine and a half of the 11 points
are just a rehashing of the same
cultural war issues that we've seen them
play for a long time the other one and a
half are just excuses to cut welfare
that's the plan guys that's the plan
as we continue to see russia's invasion
of ukraine
lead to hundreds plus casualties and
wreak global chaos we have new polling
data
who do republicans like more
leading democrats
or authoritarian vladimir putin
i know you know the answer
they prefer vladimir putin
republicans view putin more favorably
than they do leading democrats
washington post reporting
this is from yougov so if you look at
the favorability
of leaders and parties overall you see
that in the u.s biden is more favorably
looked at than putin and more favorably
looked at than trump but obama's more
popular than biden
however
when you look at republicans you see
that putin is actually seen as slightly
more favorable than joe biden
the number the number of republicans who
say putin is very favorable is slightly
higher than the number who see biden
very favorably and the number of
republicans who see putin as somewhat
favorable is significantly higher than
the portion that see joe biden as
somewhat favorable of course they love
trump and they love the republican party
and they see barack obama
very similarly
to how they see vladimir putin they
prefer
a foreign authoritarian autocrat who is
antagonistic to the united states
to joe biden and this is the result of
very effective propaganda very very
effective propaganda and
i have to tell you
it's been effective propaganda from the
right
and democrats are really bad at these
arguments republicans are not impressive
people these are not genuinely smart
people
but they know how to message effectively
they know how to put money behind that
messaging and they're crushing democrats
to the point where i mean listen yeah
i'm not going to play the both sides
game you know we should blame the left
for trump no we should primarily blame
the people who voted for trump
and then we can also talk about ways in
which the left has failed to respond to
trump fine and similarly in this case um
we can say
the left's counter-messaging hasn't been
great
to the republican propaganda but the
primarily the republican propaganda is
to blame and remember you have a
republican electorate that is very
vulnerable to that propaganda and this
is also partially a result of the
reality that the people that they pander
to
are just less likely to think critically
or outside of their own interests and it
just makes them a better target all of
those things are true and where it leads
us or where it leaves us better better
said is with republicans preferring
putin to biden as putin has launched a
brutal invasion of ukraine
violating the sovereignty of its borders
which republicans claim to care about
when it's the u.s mexico border to our
south
se i mean
sad doesn't even cover it but it is very
very sad
uh yesterday i didn't even get to this
because we were so busy with other
stories but this is a pretty big story
prosecutors in charge of the trump
criminal probe
have resigned they have resigned
the associated press reporting the two
prosecutors in charge of the manhattan
district attorney's criminal
investigation into trump and his
business dealings suddenly resigned on
wednesday
throwing the future of the probe into
question just as pressure was building
on trump a spokesperson for d.a alvin
bragg confirmed the resignations of
carrie dunn and mark pomerance two top
deputies who had been tasked with
running the investigation day to day
they started on the probe under former
d.a cyrus vance
and stayed on
done the office's former general counsel
argued before the supreme court
in a successful multi-year fight for
trump's tax records pomerance is a
former mafia prosecutor brought out of
private practice to add expertise in
white-collar investigations and has been
questioning witnesses before the grand
jury
brag spokesperson danielle filson said
we are grateful for their service and
didn't say anything else indicating the
investigation is ongoing but of course
many people saying okay the
investigation is ongoing but it is
basically over it is basically over
and now the right is saying this is
proof the investigation was bogus what
the right wants you to believe is that
the investigation into trump was
meritless and bogus and in protest these
two investigators quit there is no
evidence of that
there's just no evidence of that
what we do know with certainty is that
there is major hesitation right now from
any prosecutor to actually charge trump
so if we want to speculate a much more
reasonable speculation would be the
resignation is because the investigators
realize no matter what happens
trump's not getting charged
and they were sick of doing work that
they feel will be in vain again i'm i'm
saying
if we want to speculate
that's way more likely that there's
evidence against trump and the
investigators realized da's never going
to charge what the hell are we doing
here wasting our time
but both are mere speculation we don't
actually know that either of those is
the reason and so we can only wait and
see if we get a comment
that being said
as i've said before
i don't think trump's ever going to see
a day of prison
and i don't think these resignations
contradict
what has been my position on this for a
very very long time years at this point
if you disagree let me know you can find
me on twitter at dpakman and i want to
remind you guys we have continued
coverage of cpac live through the
weekend through the weekend
and on tuesday we will be live at 8 p.m
eastern for joe biden's state of the
union address
what will he say about uh 2022 election
what will he say about the russian
invasion of ukraine what will he say in
general we'll be live and i hope you'll
join me on twitter
on
youtube twitch and or facebook we have a
fantastic program for you today we'll
take a quick break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show primarily depends
on the support of our audience viewers
listeners people who listen to the
podcast watch a youtube clip here or
there
follow me on tick tocks or wherever it
may be you can sign up at
joinpackman.com and use the coupon code
wow22 to get a discount remember if alex
jones hates the bonus show
it's probably pretty cool oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad right
joinpakman.com is the place to sign up
let's hear from people in the audience
we do this via discord you can find our
discord at davidpakman.com
slash discord we are going to start
today
with jess in florida jess in florida
welcome
hello hello you're on the air
oh hey hi david uh if you can hear me
okay let's get into it so i have a
question
a couple questions regarding like
research literacy
okay um
i think that
as people as americans we would probably
have an easier time solving problems if
we all had a sort of like foundation on
what the problems are right
and also not only that if we could have
an agreement as to what's a fact and
what's an opinion
exactly yeah absolutely yep and i you
know i had other questions regarding
like holy texts than what that has to do
with it but getting to the point here i
was wondering uh what what your thoughts
are on uh
on
you know creating research literacy
classes
in grade schools to sort of help this on
a long term scale um
how would we do that like what could
that potentially look like and what can
people
listeners of yours who aren't teachers
or politicians do to help enact
something like that beautiful so first
and foremost the answer is yes i've
never used the term research literacy
but i've talked about bringing
epistemology critical thinking and media
literacy into every classroom starting
in i i would say at the latest in fifth
grade now how do we do it how do we do
it the difficulty is
it's basically determined at the state
level right curricula determined at the
state level overlapping with
municipalities under seen by overseen
rather by individual superintendents etc
so
the way to do this is we need activists
going to school board meetings
everywhere in order to request this
you've got to lobby the state boards of
education
and local municipalities and i'm not
saying go and behave the way the
anti-mask people behave at the school
board meetings but we need a concerted
effort to say we need media literacy
critical thinking and epistemology
coursework how do we why do we believe
the things we believe starting no later
than fifth grade and it's going to take
a lot of local activism
yeah as um as a younger person i
graduated high school in 2016. okay and
the only time i ever got any sort of
research training was like
how to use a library you know what i
mean we need to learn how to
like figure out what's true and what's
not true on the internet that's so
important absolutely absolutely jess
you've said it beautifully can i ask
what part of florida you're in
gainesville obligatory go gators that's
a pretty uh red area if i understand
correctly
it is and i have to deal with it all the
time but not for long because i'm moving
to oregon where people wear masks
beautiful beautiful all right jess thank
you so much for the call
thanks so much bye-bye david all right
just from florida in gainesville for now
but not for long
let's go next to
james in cambridge
hey david can you hear me all right i
can hear you fine james
hi uh first i was wondering um you said
something in a show um i think about a
week ago about um
that it's um it's a myth that the united
states uh ever promised um gorbachev or
anyone that nato wouldn't expand
eastwards and i was just wondering where
you had read that
because uh because i've just read some
things that are contradictory so i was
just kind of curious about that i i
don't remember the specific source but
my understanding of the story was that
it was verbally offered as a concession
at one point in negotiations but that it
was subsequently removed at the
direction of uh
us and i believe
german dignitaries and it was never
codified or signed anywhere and actually
made an agreement
okay okay i just want a clarification on
that because i just seen some
transcripts from george washington
university
that described as you said that it was
verbally promised
and my second question
um which is more to do with trump is
why is it that trump is often portrayed
as a populist because first of all the
bulk of his support actually came from
higher income people yes and secondly uh
his policies
were incredibly beneficial to the rich
for my estimation he's one of the most
elitist presidents in american history
so your conclusion is correct he's one
of the most elitist i don't i don't know
that it's accurate to say the bulk of
his support came from high income people
is it possible what you meant is high
income people supported him more than
hillary is that maybe that's what you
meant
um um yeah yeah um i i to reword what i
said on average in 2016 and 2020
the average income of his supporters was
higher than the average income of either
of the democratic nominees okay now
remember if average means mean that
could not be a super useful metric but
let's not even concern ourselves with
that because your main point is a good
one which is about policy yes trump has
been a was an incredibly elitist
president the tax reform plan
disproportionately benefited the the
very wealthy um and the things he
promised to do for middle-income people
lower-income people he didn't do and um
i don't know why he was called the
populist i mean there's two perspectives
on that one is that he's a right-wing
populist others would say right-wing
populism doesn't actually exist he just
used populist rhetoric but he's not
actually a populist it becomes more of a
semantic debate but the conclusion's the
right one trump was one of the most
pro-elitist presidents we've had
yeah he also uh destroyed a lot of labor
regulations um that um that especially
in covet were really disastrous yeah um
i would actually say that people like
aoc and bernie sanders are
more
are legitimately populist in terms of
policy substance than anybody like trump
or uh joshua or uh josh hawley i agree
with you 100
so yeah uh uh thanks for uh thanks for
taking my call david thank you apprecia
left a little prematurely there but
that's okay
um let's go next where where are we
going next
how about uh
how about jason in atlanta jason you're
on the air
hi david i'm uh calling because i was
wondering uh you have
in the past mentioned support for a
shorter work week um
first of all how many hours do you think
would be ideal i know keane's predicted
by 2030 we'd have a 15 hour work week
yeah the the the the prediction from
keynes uh has not is an old prediction
he predicted that as technology
increased productivity people would
basically have mostly time for leisure
um and
you know it's it's an old prediction
that turned out not not to be right and
there's a lot of different reasons why i
have not devoted a lot of time to the
number of hours that i think is the i
think it's different in different
industries and different types of jobs
in particular there are jobs where you
quite literally
are selling your labor an hour at a time
and so if you reduce the number of hours
in order to keep the same compensation
your hourly rate needs to go up and
that's very different for someone
working at mcdonald's versus someone who
is like a lawyer or a therapist that is
compensated hourly but has more control
over their wage so for me it's less
about that i don't have the answers to
that but
i've been very supportive of the idea
that the bulk of our work can easily be
condensed into four days in a lot of
information type jobs i want to be
really clear about that
and at the show
we condense production of our five
weekly shows
into
four days
so number of hours i don't know
[Music]
different industries different answers
but i think much of how work is
organized is not super efficient in
terms of providing the most leisure time
okay yeah thank you and you kind of are
uh you answered what my next question
was gonna be which was how we would make
up for the um
lost income because if you know most
people are working hourly if they get
their hours cut they would uh be making
less money right with salaried workers
if you
become more
inspired and more efficient by knowing
that your work week is shorter and you
kind of get the same amount of work done
you could say that takes care of itself
there are some who say well we don't
really need as much efficiency as we
actually get it would be okay if we were
not quite as a fit there's really a lot
of different opinions about that but for
the hourly worker who you know if you go
to someone who makes 15 bucks an hour
working
nine to five monday through friday and
you say great news you now only work
monday through thursday if you don't
make any other change you've taken 20 of
their income
right yeah
yeah thanks jason from atlanta very uh
very important question
uh let's go to
spencer
from california spencer you're on next
hey david a first time caller pleasure
to be on and one of the things i'm
wondering is i was watching one of the
interviewers that uh interviews that you
did
last week where
the interviewee i think raised the
possibility of having a
third political party uh forming in the
us sometime in the next couple of years
i'm wondering what your thoughts are on
that um and if you think that that's a
feasible thing
i
am very supportive of third parties i
think we are so myopically limited in
the us by having only two parties i've
also said that that in order for third
parties to really be viable in the
united states
we need to move in the direction of um
ideally some kind of ranked choice or
transferable voting system where people
wouldn't worry if i vote third party i
might be helping the person i'm the most
against for example if as someone on the
left you vote for the green party you
might actually help the republican by
taking votes from the democrats so we
need some kind of transferable or ranked
choice system number one and number two
we need to go towards public financing
of elections that will even the playing
field in terms of what is able to be
spent by parties because initially third
parties would be at a massive financial
disadvantage so i i support third
parties i would love to have strong
parties in the united states other than
democrats and republicans without the
two reforms i mentioned i don't know how
it happens
okay yeah that makes sense
uh and then i guess just another quick
question
so i've been following your channel for
a while and i see all these clips of
people like mike pillow and rudy
giuliani giuliani
always talking about how evidence is
supposedly coming out soon very scary
broad cases or whatever yeah so i'm
wondering are do you think they're
eventually going to pivot away from that
as we approach the next election cycle
and just focus on winning elections i
don't know
i almost i'm wondering at this point if
they'll just keep saying the evidence is
just around the corner until they're
dead i don't know they don't seem to
have any off-ramp from repeating that
we're about to get all the evidence
it's bizarre i don't know i don't know
when they're gonna stop talking about it
gotcha thanks for taking my call david
all right thanks spencer great to hear
from you that's spencer from california
a very powerful series of callers today
let's go next to tristan from boston
we've had a lot of technical issues with
tristan from boston in the past let's
see if we can hear from tristan today
tristan go
hey david can you hear me now i can
tristan
awesome
so
um
i was uh been waiting to ask you a
question that actually you brought up a
couple live streams ago uh earlier this
week or what was it last week
and uh it was from hillary clinton
um where
she brought up
she floated the idea of possibly suing
tucker carlson
over
[Music]
on fox news
because of
their
their constant battering of her
over
you know
the
[Music]
the
gotta
put hillary
gotta lock her up the constant hillary
disinformation
campaign that the republicans and trump
have been running since
2015
effectively
now
uh
if
if in uh kind of in an ideal world i
would say if
she or some other
uh huge figure
took
fox news to court over that and she
ended up winning
a
uh case
what do you think the ripple effect
would be
for that
i have said that if
any of these
people or media outlets
lose a defamation suit
uh i think it would do
a ton to change these sometimes
multi-year
campaigns of disinformation against
people i mean if it really
hurt fox financially
to
have pushed lies about hillary clinton
that a court found
were defamation
and it they were really damaged by it
financially i think they would have no
choice but to revisit their approach now
they of course would claim censorship
and they would claim all of these
different things
but when when hillary clinton mentions
actual malice which is you know
related to defamation
if they were to lose such a suit i think
it would completely change what these
media outlets are willing to put on the
air
yeah that's i mean that's what uh
that kind of reminded me of uh
when hannity
was saying uh to tulsi
yeah you kind of gotta back off this uh
really obvious putin
standing
yesterday
when
it was really really obvious that she
was doing this or we uh
we might
you know get accused of being russia
operatives
right absolutely tristan from boston
thank you so much for the call we're
going to take a very quick break if
you're holding on to talk to me
hold on just a little bit longer because
we'll go right back to the phones after
this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show okay let's hear from a
few more people you can join the
discussion on our discord at
davidpakman.com
discord
let's go next to marcus
from manitoba marcus you are on the air
hello david
uh hello
my question for you is
why do you think
uh
all these self-identified left-wing
populists
a prominent left-wing populists
online and in real politics
have have tended to go in
a similar direction over the course of
their political careers
i'm thinking people like
uh your friend and mine uh tulsi gabbard
and
jimmy dorey
and matt taibi
tending to go in a similar direction of
you know
kind of being receptive to
russian
friendly towards russia
kind of
repeating or tending to be
uh
promoting promoting kind of narratives
similar to
the kind of things that we see on the
right coming from trump and such why
you think this is what what is causing
this
you know i really i really don't know um
i don't think there is one answer like
for example
if we were to just say these
faux left wing populists
are doing this because of money for
example
um
maybe maybe to some degree
for some of them i don't know that there
really is that much money in it so i
don't i don't think that's really the
explanation
um
maybe it's for attention i mean
attention is linked to money maybe some
of them are like you know i i just kind
of blend in
if i just do actual leftism so i'm going
to do this kind of wacky reactionary
faux populist thing maybe that's kind of
a factor
another part might be some of them might
actually
have been confused about what their
actual politics are and maybe they
thought they were on the left and then
they realize
they're actually kind of not and they
make that more clear in their public
pronouncements
um i i don't think there's one answer
but it is weird because it's like you
could just say you're on the right you
don't really have to claim to be on the
left but have reactionary positions you
can just and look tool c is being
welcomed at cpac now so clearly there's
space for them on the right you know i i
don't know that i have one answer well i
do have uh
my own personal theories okay about why
this is yeah it may be controversial
given that i i know that
uh you know previous callers have voiced
uh
sort of opposing opinions about populism
that you know
i recall someone said something like uh
oh trump
why is trump called a populist trump
isn't a real populist right-wing
populism isn't real populism
i think that gets something
fundamentally wrong
it
sort of presupposes that
populists
or populism requires being honest about
your populist beliefs i don't think it
does right i think populism is a
rhetorical
tool primarily well or rather like there
are different definitions of populism
right no but i think you're right i mean
i've commented before
the reason populist rhetoric can be so
tricky
is that there can be any policy
underneath it and the populism itself is
not policy and like the great example
was you know you could have
bernie and tucker
similarly saying we've got a real
problem here where the middle class is
being taken advantage of
and we've got to support the middle
class we need to make sure that legal
infrastructure and and all this stuff
supports the middle class bernie would
have one solution and tucker would be
like and it's brown people coming from
mexico that are the problem right so so
i think that you're getting exactly at
what i've said for years
yes i'm and i mean i think there's a
substantive difference between
uh people who are both called populists
like bernie and tucker carlson
uh
er i don't think tucker has any plans to
[Music]
he obviously has no actual policy
proposals uh that could solve the
problems he's talking about right
whereas bernie might although i'm also
somewhat skeptical that he is really all
that pragmatic
or whatever i i still like bernie
sanders
but uh
i i do think that
uh
what unites them both is
and what unites all strands of populism
is primarily the rhetoric that he uses
yes and i think so and here's where
there will be some who will disagree
with one of the things that you're
saying
there are some who will hear what you're
saying and they'll go well tucker's not
really a populist he's actually an a
privileged elitist right winger
but i think the point you're making is
there's really no such thing as a
populist populism is a is a rhetoric and
you've got to look at policy some people
would just disagree with you as to what
populism is is it policy or is it
rhetoric or is it
both well exactly and
i would say furthermore that it like
the very rhetoric of populism it is
defined by its def its
its creation of this dichotomy between
the elite and some nebulous category
known as the people both of them are
really nebulous categories and often
the populists themselves are coming from
elite positions this has been the case
since really ancient times yes populism
has been a strategy that's worked in
democracies
since democracy first came into
existence think of cleon in athens think
of julius caesar he was a populist
and
uh and
all of them or a lot of them do tend to
come from the elite classes and they
frame themselves as being sort of class
traders being like actually on the side
of you the people
uh when in fact often
it is just a rhetorical tool
uh
to allow them to gain position of power
yes i agree with you completely and
there are many in my audience who will
disagree but i really appreciate you
laying it out so clearly
thank you david all right there is
marcus from manitoba
dropping the hammer
in a serious manner
uh okay
let's go
next where are we going to go how about
garrett from buffalo
garrett from buffalo you're on the air
hey can you hear me yes i can
oh awesome sorry thanks for having me i
really appreciate it pleasure
um so my question like
it pertains to student debt um because
it's been such a big issue this year
sure
i just had this crazy idea that was like
if donald trump's like supported
canceling student debt that it really
could make a big rift in the democratic
party i mean at least in the people the
voters and i was just wondering your
like thoughts on that topic i think
you're completely right let's hope he
doesn't uh think of it you know i mean i
don't know
i don't see trump coming up with that
but i agree with you that at this point
cancellation of student debt has become
such a topic of interest on the left
which the right is basically against i
mean understand that that if trump came
out in favor of canceling student debt
it would go against all the principles
of the right of supposed personal
responsibility you choose you chose to
take the debt we're not going to bail
you out um all these different things on
a lot of things
keep going but trump has done it on some
other things i think it would absolutely
fracture the democratic party and so i
hope trump doesn't come up with it now
that being said
it is an undeniable fact that joe biden
has cancelled more student debt than any
former any other president now you might
say wait but david he didn't do it he
didn't do it no biden has canceled
student debt
for certain um attendees of for-profit
colleges and through some other programs
in terms of dollars no one has canceled
more student debt than joe biden he has
not done this thing that people want him
to do which is hey everybody gets 10
grand taken off of their debt or
everybody gets 50 grand taken off of
their debt he has not done that it has
been targeted but i think if trump were
to come forward and say i will cancel
all student debt or something
joe biden would be able to say no one's
cancelled more student debt than me and
he would technically be correct
yeah that makes sense and even if trump
did say that do you think it would like
push biden to like maybe do it maybe in
the end like maybe so yeah
all right thanks for answering my
question i appreciate it yeah my
pleasure interesting idea there from uh
from from garrett
uh
wow
let's go next to ricardo or or is it
richardo from italy you're on the air
hi david can you hear me yes i can
oh that's awesome
so
very quick very quick context from my
end so i'm italian by birth but
i only lived there as a as a young kid
and then i worked for 20 years in costa
rica and now i'm in the boston area and
i've been working here for five years
got it so
so my question is like the modern world
is really not suited for for the current
way of doing politics in the way that i
truly have never felt really represented
by any political party and i don't
really have a voice because
i can only vote in a place where i never
lived as an adult and i've never paid
taxes in so if i vote in italy i get
called a bunch of names saying you don't
really have a saying here
um
because you don't really have to face
the consequences you've been gone for so
long yeah yeah exactly in the u.s i
can't really complain because i'm not a
citizen yet i pay the same if not more
taxes for being a foreigner working here
same thing in costa rica for the
previous 20 years right i was always the
outsider never really had any
representation and and if you think
about it the whole concept of u.s
democracy is based on
uh no taxation or representation right
so it's cr it's crazy that we live in a
world where i don't really have a true
saying on anything yet i have to bear
the consequences of other people's
choices yeah i mean to play devil's
advocate there are some who would say
you know you do have a say in that
as a resident you can still lobby your
elected officials and they still are
supposed to listen to you even though
you're not a citizen but you certainly
don't have a vote in the way everybody
else does yeah i don't really have an
answer i mean you're you're not you're
not wrong um and i think
what some might say is
if you've been in other places that long
you really should go through the process
of getting citizenship so you can get
that vote
but no you're you're uh you're in an in
a kind of in-between situation i i
understand
it it takes so long and doing things the
right way is really more difficult than
most people uh that are born in this
country uh would ever understand
absolutely absolutely yeah
uh what part of italy are you from
uh i was born in milan oh okay i've been
a beautiful city
yep
i mean the the good thing is that i can
speak italian spanish and english so at
least i have that yeah you know
interestingly when i was in torino for a
wedding a couple of years ago there were
a lot of immigrants there from central
america and they spoke english spanish
and italian all very well
awesome yeah all right thank you so much
for the call i appreciate it
all right very good uh okay everybody
that will do it for today i know more
people wanted to talk to me i know it i
see it i feel it but i can't get to
everybody so we will take live calls
again
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
welcome back to the show let's go to
this week's mailbag an increasingly
popular segment with the lovers and the
haters of the david pakman show you can
email info
davidpakman.com please don't abuse the
email address guys there's so many
people that we just have to block from
our email and filter their emails to
where they belong right into the trash
but uh it's still great hearing from
from so many of you before we jump into
the email piece let's do like one little
extra which is a tweet response and this
goes to remember my monday segment about
i'm no longer going to
uh apologize to the idiots sort of thing
here was like i tweeted about russia
this week and someone wrote back dude
you're regurgitating cia talking points
what a loser take
um give me a break dude go away i don't
care what you think and i'm not doing
the show for you you can go away find
some show that uh is more pleasant for
you but we i just don't care i just
don't care
um i've had the other one is you're
regurgitating dnc talking points man
we're not paid by the dnc i have no
contact with anyone at the cia i don't
even know what cia talking points are
when it comes to this
i just don't care the show is not for
you please move on no longer explaining
away or apologizing
corey wrote in and had a very good
reminder
corey said what happened to obama gate
sir at one point trump declared obama
gate as the crime of the century he
never detailed it but claimed everyone
knew what it was and the evidence was
going to come out i know that it's just
part of the trump griff but when these
claims never come to fruition how do
otherwise intelligent people keep
falling for this well they're not really
otherwise intelligent cory is it a
matter of personality cult brainwashing
or do people just want to be insiders
and pretend to be in on the grift
there's different reasons why different
people fall for obvious lies yeah if you
don't remember the whole obama gate
thing trump at one point started using
that term obamagate and saying it's the
biggest political crime of the century
um
and a lot of people
would ask like reporters
what is it what is it and trump would go
you know what it is
and would attack the media and the
evidence was always just on the brink of
coming out and of course like it never
did it never did come out
and um i don't know what obama gate was
was obama gate them they spied on my
campaign was obama gate the tan suit was
obama gate when trump when obama had a
particular type of mustard on a burger
uh i don't know at this point what obama
gate was supposed to be but rest assured
it doesn't exist
it doesn't exist
a very strong shot across the bow fired
by ralph
ralph wrote in and said harry situation
david no politics in this email
i just wanted to let you know that your
facial hair
is much better than farren cousins
not as good as brett ehrlich's though
i love your show watch it every day on
youtube keep up the good work this is
extraordinarily divisive
extraordinarily divisive and i would
encourage ralph to rethink write in
about something less divisive like you
know the israeli-palestinian conflict or
something like that no in all
seriousness i can barely grow a beard so
i don't even know i i did not expect any
commentary on my facial hair
um nor do i have anything to brag about
quite frankly i just this is what when i
don't shave for two weeks this is what
it looks like and it's pathetic and
that's okay
but that's it i don't have anything else
to add about that
will roden about trump's presidential
portrait says hey david really enjoy the
show and the way you discuss news almost
all of which i agree with
one small point i don't agree with you
on
is marjorie taylor green's use of
gazpacho instead of gestapo i in no way
support her on anything
but i do think
she said gazpacho on purpose
to ridicule pelosi to attract more
attention into rhyolous libs it was not
a slip of the tongue or an indication of
her ignorance as if any more were needed
i disagree and the reason i disagree is
number one i don't think marjorie taylor
green is smart enough to think of that
and number two
it's not really helped her in any way
that she has been widely ridiculed for
saying gazpacho instead of gestapo
it's not gotten more people to agree
that nancy pelosi is the mask gestapo or
whatever it is that marjorie taylor
green meant to say
uh i i just don't think so and a couple
of people have proposed
some version of that theory
i i just i just don't think she's got it
in her and um later in the email and i
apologize that it got cut off the topic
is trump's presidential portrait will
went on to say
do i think that biden will welcome trump
to the white house to unveil
his presidential portrait the way
prior presidents have welcomed their
predecessors
i think the answer is no i do i don't
know why or how it will work out
this way
but i do not expect to see trump at the
white house
having his portrait unveiled with biden
standing there i don't expect it part of
it has to do with trump continues to say
he actually won the election and that
biden's not even the rightful president
so i don't expect that to be the case
if you disagree with me
let me know
toby wrote in
toby says i remember way back in the
1980s and 1990s when tv news had
commentators they would generally
announce whoever it was is a commentator
have a message on screen announcing that
is what they did
i figured this was to separate them from
the journalists i find it interesting
eventually doing it this way was done
away with therefore blurring the lines
between journalists and commentators
yeah this is a very astute um
observation
right now many so-called news channels
are based on the idea that they blur
reporting and news and fox news does
this expertly
they will for example not identify
that we have now shifted from me giving
you facts to someone giving opinion and
unfortunately a lot of people are too
ignorant to realize that that shift has
taken place they will often
crowbar in opinion into their news hours
by saying so here's like a way it might
go
on a thursday night tucker carlson will
go
it looks to me like the fbi might have
done the january 6 trump riots
of course that's an opinion not based in
any fact the next day fox news hours
will go
last night on his program tucker carlson
stated that he believes the fbi
and then like now let's bring in two
people to debate it did the fbi do the
riots or not
and it all becomes part of the news
cycle
um yes
it would be much better to go back to
those quaint moments here to give us his
opinion which is not the opinion of this
network and it is only an opinion is
tucker carlson or what you know whatever
the case may be
toby uh absolutely spot on observation
joseph rhoden and says david sir your
comparison about high schoolers asking
questions to milton friedman versus the
modern day high schoolers asking
questions to ben shapiro is apt but i
think it misses an important detail so
background what i said was
you can see the decline in sort of
education and competence
in that if you look at
high schoolers of the era asking
questions to milton friedman or noam
chomsky and you see the questions asked
of ben shapiro
or or college students
that it the caliber has declined
dramatically and i see it as a sign of
the
anti-and pseudo-intellectualist movement
and the decline of education critical
thinking etc joseph says any high school
that would invite ben shapiro
is probably not turning out the
brightest students in the first place
talk about academic standards therefore
it stands to reason that the questions
from these students would be
inarticulate let's be fair you know okay
so that's fair i mean i guess the idea
here is
someone who would want to go see milton
friedman speak
is by definition
going to be more of a thinking person
than someone who would want to go see
ben shapiro speak
i don't know i mean there might be
something to that there might be
something to that but i think
part of the issue part of the decline is
in
who
people want to go and see speak
and uh
i think that there's been a dramatic
change there as well so a fair point but
i don't know that it really tells us
everything we need to know
damien writes in and says about the
midterms david why does everyone assume
republicans will take back the house in
22
despite the fact that democrats took
back the white house and senate in 2021
well first of all it was 2020. but
that is why so damien here here's what
you have to understand
if you didn't know
the history of american politics you
might think well democrats did well in
2020 so by definition they have momentum
going into 2021 uh 2022 not the way it
works historically when one party wins
back the white house in one election
year in the next immediate midterm the
other party takes back control of the
house and or senate or extends their
control
and we can talk about why that is often
there's sort of this idea of a pendulum
that when it swings one way it then
comes back and swings the other way a
lot of different reasons but
historically that's the way it happens
usually when one party takes the white
house they then lose the house and or
senate so that's why we expect it to
happen and indeed it is looking that way
unfortunately
last email is from glenn glenn says
david love your show but
i'm not a fan of you referring to mike
lindell as pillow
he's definitely an unhinged man worthy
of your ire but by referring to him as
pillow i feel that you're lowering
yourself to trump's level of using
derogatory nicknames for those that
displease him
though pillow isn't really that
derogatory just appears unseemly beneath
you i would prefer you refer to him by
his real name i kind of disagree listen
pillow is not a serious person mike
lindell is not a serious person
and part of making it clear that you
know it's not
senator mitt romney has taken a position
on tax reform and we're not going to
call him mittens right
i would agree with you there
pillow's not a serious person and the
fact that mike pillow has even gotten a
place in american politics thanks to
trump who was also not serious i believe
at every level
we need to be ridiculing the fact that
this guy has a voice
and so i think in his case referring to
him as pillow is absolutely fine um
anecdotally i think people in the
audience tend to agree with me
on that one
if you disagree
by all means
let me know
we also have a great bonus show coming
up for you today the bonus show is for
our website members we depend on website
members to fund this show you know we've
got cpac going on right now and cpac is
wild cartoonish reactionary extremism
and we should laugh at it but
but but but remember
cpac should also be a reminder
at how much more seriously the right
takes
funding
organization
for right-wing media and right-wing
politics okay
on the left
we stink at it the right crushes us with
funding right with me media funding
right-wing conferences so remember
let's support
media we think is doing something
valuable if you think this show is doing
something valuable consider getting a
membership at joinpakman.com it's very
cheap and you'll get access to the daily
bonus show every day you'll get a
commercial free audio and video feed of
the full show
every day six hours before it publishes
for everybody else
and
you'll be supporting something that
hopefully you think is worthwhile sign
up at joinpakman.com we have a coupon
code you can use if you want that code
is wow 22 wow 22 we will see you on the
bonus show in a moment